l'eau la boue et rentrait également dans
le banc de cholet toujours par bach
derrière vous accumulez christophe rosso
est l'une des victimes de l'inondation
du quartier de la boissière à plaisir ce
vendredi vers 7 heures du matin une
rupture de canalisation de 60 cm de
diamètre à proximité de l'école alain
fournier à entrer une submersion
partielle du secteur
l'incident a entraîné des dégâts chez
habitants au niveau du jardin on a été
inondée sur toute la partie du jardin la
terrasse à a commencé à être inondées
également c'est surtout surtout le coin
détente qui a eu qui a eu pas mal de
dégâts jacuzzi qui est maintenant hors
service le coin à cuisine extérieure qui
est hors service aussi plusieurs
milliers de mètres cubes d'eau se sont
également déversé sur le stade des
peupliers les terrains rénové en 2012
pour un coût de 2 millions d'euros ont
été fortement endommagés les terrains
synthétiques sont je dirais en a
sèchement puisqu'on attend de voir
comment les choses se passent tout de
suite on a imaginé qu'il puisse ne pas
être du tout utilisable par le sportif
d'ailleurs nous avons fait l arrêté pour
qu'il ne soit pas utilisable on va
attendre que ça sèche un peu puis on
verra ce qu'il en est mais j'ai bien
peur qu'il faille les remettre en état
complètement une décision concernant la
rénovation des terrains sera prise d'ici
trois semaines par la mairie les
rencontres sportives sont pour le moment
reporter